et pendant ce temps la loi sur le report
de l'âge légal fait son chemin le texte
a été validé aujourd'hui en commission
mixte paritaire ce qui ouvre la voie un
vote définitif sur le texte demain au
Sénat puis à l'Assemblée nationale tout
dépendra de la capacité du gouvernement
à s'assurer une majorité
contestation dans la rue on l'a vu mais
aussi dans les entreprises publiques de
l'énergie plus de 300 personnes de
plusieurs sites en France se sont
retrouvés aujourd'hui devant la centrale
nucléaire de Saint-Laurent-des-Eaux en
Loir-et-Cher entre baisses de production
et coupure d'électricité ciblée il
promettent un durcissement du mouvement
romain Delville
c'est tout le secteur de l'énergie
mobilisée contre la réforme des
retraites qui avait rendez-vous ce matin
devant la centrale nucléaire de
Saint-Laurent-des-Eaux pour l'occasion
des représentants nationaux de la CGT FO
CFDT et CFE-CGC était présent en
Loir-et-Cher la semaine dernière les
actions qui ont été menées ont été super
bien menés par par les agents en grève
on va essayer cette semaine d'aller
encore plus fort sur les coupures
ciblées sur les blocages des sites
gaziers Elec mais aussi sur les remises
en énergie environ 300 salariés étaient
réunis à Saint-Laurent des salariés des
centrales de Chinon Belleville
Flamanville Dampierre plus des salariés
du secteur gazier venu aussi pour
protester contre la fin des régimes
spéciaux tout le monde va prendre deux
enfermes donc nous on échappera pas
c'est pour ça qu'on estime que cette
réforme est complètement injuste c'est
pour ça que malheureusement le seul
moyen aujourd'hui c'est de se mobiliser
c'est de poser sur l'économie parce que
c'est le seul levier vraiment qui va
pouvoir faire plier ce gouvernement ici
la grève est reconductible jour après
jour les syndicats travaillent main dans
la main et regrettent le comportement de
leur actionnaire majoritaire l'état une
forte mobilisation tout le temps
même point alors on a chacun nos
divergences mais qui revendiquent les
mêmes les mêmes points de blocage et
malgré tout on n'est pas entendu il y a
pas donc les organisations syndicales
n'ont pas été reçues par l'exécutif donc
on a un gouvernement qui est sourd dans
le secteur de l'énergie la grève
reconductible est officiellement lancée
depuis le 4 mars des actions ciblées
pourraient se durcir si la réforme
venait à passer demain à l'Assemblée
nationale donc maintenant